ONES YOU LOVE.
HERE'S SEAN HANNITY.
>> Sean: THANKS.
A LOT OF NEWS TONIGHT.
WELCOME TO "HANNITY."
WE BEGIN WITH THIS FOX NEWS
ALERT.
JOE BIDEN'S MULTI-TRILLION
DOLLAR STUDENT LOAN HAND OUT WAS
BLOCKED BY A FEDERAL JUDGE
DELIVERING WHAT IS A SERIOUS
BLOW TO THE ADMINISTRATION AS
PLANNED TO REDISTRIBUTE FUNDS
FROM BLUE COLLAR WORKERS, TO
HARD WORKING MEN AND WOMEN OF
THIS COUNTRY TO GRAD STUDENTS
AND SOCIALOLOGY MAJORS EVEN
THOSE THAT WENT TO HARVARD AND
YALE AND IVY LEAGUE
INSTITUTIONS.
WE'LL HAVE MORE IN JUST A
MOMENT.
NOW, WE ALSO HAVE TONIGHT OTHER
BREAKING NEWS OUT OF ARIZONA.
A MAJOR UPDATE IS IMMINENT.
A BIG NEW BATCH OF RESULTS IS
EXPECTED AT ANY MOMENT.
THINGS HAVE TURNED DRAMATICALLY
BETTER FOR BLAKE MASTERS IN
ARIZONA.
KARI LAKE SEEMS TO BE THE SURE
WINNER THE GUBERNATORIAL RACE.
AND ADAM LAXALT IS THE ODDS ON
FAVORITE IN HIS SENATE RACE.
WE EXPECT AN UPDATED VOTE DURING
THIS HOUR.
STAY TUNED.
IF WE'RE ABLE TO MAKE A CALL IN
THIS HOUR, WE WILL.
FORTUNATELY IN ARIZONA, NEVADA,
CALIFORNIA AND A FEW OTHER
LOCATIONS ALL AROUND THE
COUNTRY, THE VOTE COUNT IS GOING
ON AGAIN AND AGAIN IN
PERPETUITY.
COULD TAKE DAYS OR WEEKS.
AND IN THE VERY COLD STATE OF
ALASKA THAT I LOVE, WE MAY NOT
KNOW ANYTHING UNTIL AROUND
THANKSGIVING.
THIS IS INSANITY AND IT'S NOT
OKAY.
FIVE WEEKS AFTER FLORIDA
SUFFERED A DEVASTATING
CATEGORY FOUR HURRICANE AND
WE'RE STILL PRAYING FOR OUR
FRIENDS IN SOUTHWEST, FLORIDA,
THE STATE MANAGED WITH SO MUCH
DAMAGE TO COUNT ALL 7.5 MILLION
BALLOTS AS MARCO RUBIO SAID IN
FIVE HOURS.
IN CLARK COUNTY IN NEVADA,
OFFICIALS ARE STILL IN THE
PROCESS OF COUNTING A MERE
50,000 REMAINING BALLOTS.
48 HOURS AFTER THE ELECTION.
TODAY THE COUNTY REGISTRAR JUST
SAID THAT IT WILL TAKE SEVERAL
MORE DAYS TO COUNT THOSE 50,000
VOTES.
TELLING REPORTERS THAT THE
COUNTY CAN'T DO IT ANY FASTER.
CAN WE HIRE THE PEOPLE IN
FLORIDA?
JUST AN IDEA.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> MY STAFF HAS BEEN WORKING
DILIGENTLY.
WE'VE BEEN HERE FROM EARLY IN
THE MORNING UNTIL LATE AT NIGHT.
WE'VE BEEN FULLY STAFFED.
WE'RE WORKING AS HARD AS WE CAN
TO GET THE BALLOTS COUNTED.
WHETHER WE LIKE IT OR NOT,
THERE'S NO WAY THAT WE CAN MOVE
ANY FASTER THAN WE'RE MOVING.
WE STILL HAVE OVER 50,000
BALLOTS THAT NEED TO BE COUNTED.
THOSE ARE IN VARIOUS STAGES IN
THE PROCESS OF VALIDATION BEFORE
THEY GO TO THE COUNTING BOARD
AND FINALLY ULTIMATELY TO GET TO
TABULATION WHERE WE'RE ABLE TO
READ THEM IN TO THE SYSTEM.
>> Sean: THINK OF WHAT MARCO
RUBIO SAID.
7.5 MILLION BALLOTS COUNTED IN
LESS THAN FIVE HOURS.
THEY'RE NOT GOING TO KNOW
ANYTHING, 50,000 BALLOTS, UNTIL
THE WEEKEND?
YOU CAN'T MAKE THIS UP.
I'M LAUGHING BECAUSE I WANT TO
CRY.
AS OF NOW, ADAM LAXALT IS STILL
UP AND IN A BETTER POSITION TO
WIN THIS RACE TONIGHT THAN HE
WAS LAST NIGHT.
INCHES AWAY FROM VICTORY NOW.
HE WILL JOIN US TOMORROW WITH
THE VERY LATEST OUT THERE.
LINDSEY GRAHAM WILL WEIGH-IN.
HE HAS ALL THE NUMBERS.
SADLY WHEN WE GO TO ARIZONA, THE
SITUATION BELIEVE IT OR NOT IS
MORE CHAOTIC.
HOWEVER, THE NEWS CLEARLY IS
BENEFITTING KARI LAKE AND BLAKE
MASTERS.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> WHEN DO YOU ANTICIPATE THE
VOTES WILL BE COUNTED IN TOTAL,
THE 400,000 PLUS VOTES?
>> WE HAVE -- WE WILL BE GOING
INTO NEXT WEEK.
THERE'S SOME ONIES, TWOEYS.
I THINK WE'LL SEE THE LIONS
SHARE WRAP UP BY EARLY NEXT
WEEK.
>> CAN YOU GIVE ME A DAY OR ARE
WE TALKING MONDAY?
>> MAY BE.
AS LONG AS YOU WON'T HOLD ME TO
IT.
I THINK THAT'S WHAT WE'RE
LOOKING AT AT THIS POINT.
>> AGAIN, CAN WE HIRE THE GUYS
IN FLORIDA?
THEY DID 7.5 MILLION IN FIVE
HOURS.
THAT'S MARICOPA COUNTY WHERE
400,000 BALLOTS ARE YET TO BE
COUNTED.
THIS IS AFTER MANAGING TO COUNT
A WHOPPING 62,000 VOTES
YESTERDAY.
BASED ON NUMBERS FROM THE A.P.,
OVER 650,000 VOTES ARE STILL NOT
COUNTED STATEWIDE IN ARIZONA.
ACCORDING TO MY SOURCES, I AM
BEING TOLD -- WE'LL ASK KARI
LAKE IN A FEW MINUTES -- OUT OF
THE 650,000, AROUND 400,000 OF
THOSE VOTES ARE DAY OF, DROP OFF
BALL LOTS THAT TEND TO
OVERWHELMINGLY FAVOR
REPUBLICANS.
THAT MEANS BLAKE MASTERS
CAMPAIGN IS SAYING THEY'RE NOW
AVERAGING 68% OF THAT DAY OF
PERSONAL HAND-OFF DROP OFF ON
ELECTION DAY.
IF THAT PATTERN CONTINUES, HE
WOULD BECOME THE ODDS-ON
FAVORITE TO WIN THAT SENATE
RACE.
ANYTHING CAN HAPPEN.
IN THE LAST 72 HOURS, WE'VE SEEN
BATCHES OF BALLOTS SLOWLY
TRICKLING IN FROM HERE, THERE,
EVERYWHERE SEEMINGLY AT RANDOM.
YESTERDAY WE THOUGHT 412,000 AND
A FEW OUTSKIRT COUNTIES, RURAL
COUNTIES WILL COME IN AND THAT'S
IT.
TURNS OUT IT'S 400,000 DAY-OF
BALLOTS REMAINING.
THIS HAS TO CHANGE BECAUSE IT'S
650,000 BALLOTS AS OF TODAY.
YESTERDAY WAS 400 AND CHANGE.
IT'S UNFAIR TO EVERY CANDIDATE,
EVERY CITIZEN IN ARIZONA, EVERY
PERSON IN NEVADA, EVERY PERSON
THAT VOTED IN THE OTHER 47
STATES THAT HAVE GIVEN US FOR
THE MOST PART WITH WHAT
EXCEPTIONS THE FINAL VOTE
TALLIES.
UNFORTUNATELY THE PERSON IN
CHARGE OF ARIZONA'S ELECTIONS
HAS A HUGE CONFLICT OF INTEREST.
THE SECRETARY STATE, KATIE
HOBBS, HAS NOT BEEN AT ALL
TRANSPARENT IN ANY WAY.
WE DON'T KNOW THE EXACT NUMBER
OF OUTSTANDING BALLOTS AND WE
DON'T KNOW WHEN THEY'LL FINALLY
BE COUNTED AND AN EXECUTION WHY
IT'S TAKING SO LONG.
MY MESSAGE GETS SERIOUS TO
ARIZONA, NEVADA AND EVERY OTHER
STATE STILL COUNTING VOTES.
YOU HAVE A SERIOUS PROBLEM.
THIS IS DRAWN OUT WHY TOO LONG.
IT'S CONVOLUTED, CONFUSING.
THE PROCESS DOES NOT INSPIRE ANY
CONFIDENCE AT ALL IN THE
PROCESS.
AND PEOPLE MAY QUESTION THE
RESULTS AS A RESULT.
IT SIMPLY IS NOT FAIR TO
ANYBODY.
ENTIRE COUPRIES IN EUROPE AND
SOUTH AMERICA AND ASIA, THEY
COUNT VOTES IN LESS THAN A DAY.
THEY CALL IT A DAY.
CANADA, FRANCE, SOUTH KOREA, THE
U.K., THEY ALL USE PAPER BALLOTS
AND ARE ABLE TO COUNT 100% OF
THE VOTE ON ELECTION NIGHT.
BUT CLARK COUNTY, NEVADA, JUST
CAN'T GO ANY FASTER AT A
MINIMUM.
IT LOOKS REALLY BAD.
THIS HAS TO CHANGE.
ALL THIS, YOU KNOW, MONTHS-LONG
VOTING, SIX WEEKS OF VOTING,
EIGHT MONTHS OF VOTING, DROPS
BOXES HERE, THERE, EVERYWHERE,
NO TAB YOU LATERS THAT WORK.
HOW ABOUT WE MAKE VOTING DAY A
NATIONAL HOLIDAY?
HOW ABOUT WE START THERE?
HOW ABOUT WE THEN HAVE ABSENTEE
BALLOTS FOR THE SICK, THE
INFIRMED, THE ELDERLY, PEOPLE
THAT WON'T BE IN TOWN ELECTION
DAY AND EVERYONE ELSE SHOW UP.
YOU HAVE PARTISAN OBSERVERS
WATCHING THE VOTE COUNT AND
EVERYBODY GETS THE ELECTION
RESULTS AT THE END OF THE NIGHT.
IF IT'S CLOSE, RECOUNT IT AGAIN
AND AGAIN.
WE HAVE TO HAVE INTEGRITY IN THE
SYSTEM.
DON'T GET ME STARTED WITH
ALASKA.
IN ORDER TO LET'S SEE HAVE THE
HUGE ADVANTAGE IN HER FAVOR, THE
STATE'S SERVE SERVING SENATOR
INSTITUTING RANK VOTING, THE
LISA MURKOWSKI PROTECT ACT.
THIS SYSTEM REQUIRES VOTERS TO
RANK THEIR CHOICES.
IN OTHER WORDS, BECAUSE LISA
MURKOWSKI IS WELL-LIKED AMONG
DEMOCRATS BUT NOT WELL-LIKED
AMONG REPUBLICANS, SHE CAN DRAW
SUPPORT FROM BOTH PARTIES WITH A
SECOND PLACE RANKING.
THAT INCREASES DRAMATICALLY HER
CHANCES AGAINST A REAL
REPUBLICAN IN THIS RACE IN
PARTICULAR, KELLY CHUBAKA THAT
IS BEATING HER ON ELECTION DAY
VOTING.
IT WILL TAKE WEEKS TO PLAY OUT.
CHUBAKA HAS A LEAD BUT THE
RESULTS WILL GREATLY CHANGE IN
THE COMING WEEKS BECAUSE THE TEN
POINTS THAT THE DEMOCRATIC
CANDIDATE GOT IS MORE LIKELY TO
VOTE FOR LISA MURKOWSKI BECAUSE
LISA MURKOWSKI VOTES WITH
DEMOCRATS 67% OF THE TIME.
IT'S A DISGRACE.
BACK TO OUR TOP STORY.
ALL EYES ARE ON ARIZONA AND
NEVADA.
THESE TWO STATES WILL DECIDE THE
BALANCE OF POWER IN THE U.S.
SNAKES.
THERE'S TWO MAJOR GUBERNATORIAL
RACES THAT ARE STILL HANGING IN
THE BALANCE.
IN ARIZONA, KARI LAKE IS
CONFIDENT THE REMAINING VOTES
WILL PUT H